velate di ragazzi venuti a questo video
sono parigi oggi siamo al sud
so come si chiami questo gioco però ce
ciccio ciao ragazzi basta anche se anche
qua la ciao ragazzi
[Risate]
hai fatto un buon gela regista vabbè
chiama roommate simulator non mette in
inglese e in italiano vuol dire
[Musica]
la stanza con la mia come si chiama la
camera
la stanza dai non ci deve arrivare to
roommate scommesso te amico è a roma
estate che prende sono doppie
matrimoniali distanza ok ok simulatore
di compagnie distanza linkiamo così
magari non parli di stato nel 2000 è
perfetto noi siamo compagni sta in
questo momento l'apertura del gioco è
fantastica perché il menù è ricco
infatti se vogliamo andare sulle opzioni
si sono le zebre c'è una tipa in questo
nome è molto strano
credo che sia lei il roommate non lo so
lei allora siamo in questa brevi non ci
ho mai giocato solo non so che cosa mi
hanno consigliato però sta tipa qua deve
stare ferma terapie spiega questa la mia
roommate left click to be nice
il tasto sinistro 6 gentile col tasto
destro è il testo destro destro poi
puntata le macine cosa a travedona vai a
fare quei centimetri poi cuoricini non
gliene frega più niente a termine frega
na sega donne quando quando è così che
fissa una testata e fanno bene ma chi è
chi ha fatto la casa questi qua c'è chi
rakim a caltech dannosi detto chi manca
il tetto dettaglio che se piove un cane
per colore incazzata sono un senzatetto
vediamo haibike anfratto una casa con un
lavoro di sé tagliato non c'ha manco le
finestre e se c'era il guardi il centro
hai voluto vivere dove non c'è altra
gente è perché ti dava segno la gente
questo il risultato non c'è niente c'è
la tv o almeno la knox cene stessa che
poi prenderla tesoro tieni guarda che
bello enrico papi
tu non puoi attivare le cose poi sono
lanciando ciardi vabbè ognuno ha i suoi
metodi stanno a fa il letto ma
facciamole perché dolce se prova mi
piace è uguale a prima
vabbè ma che viene adottato le cose di
sopra di fatto knock down no
a casa o non ha scoperto ma scusa ma ho
re ca no soprattutto ma come hanno
scriptato dei movimenti da weimar
voglio vedere che lo fai one was no lui
è un mito in se le cose le fa uguale lo
fa uguale più forte che fanno più veloce
di un dual e davide cava che cosa
succede
si è calmata che al mondo questo casino
tesoro ha posto cuoricini codici di voci
ma comunque questa non è la mia ragazza
il mio compagno di stanza
quindi il cielo a far conto io left
click ma non fa niente se le possiamo
vedere se poi destra neanche dal suo
stesso senza il glitch ad oggi va bene
allora che pulisce il bagno amore a
posto ma cosa barba poi con come ma più
velocissimo ma di gigantesco 50 tesoro
non venire gran casino qua se cavolata
senza ciao all'uscita l'immondizia è
comunque è un gioco da premi nobel
no tesoro non guardare non guardare che
tu fai fiorellini non si chiude questa
città sono di chiudi chiude no vabbè ma
in un punto molto ravvicinata pulce fa
credere come potete fare volo nel corso
per l'animazione di persone personaggi
esatto di attaccare questi si è
bellissimo allora il frigo scomparsa con
magari tricot cioè con attenzione o
aspettavamo una reazione capire
finché sono incazzato e giustamente però
rimane lì ad arcore
l'aria e nelle nostra nemica servi il
più cibo ha moltiplicato il pane che il
gioco è allora che ti ci devi impegnare
permette a cantare non vincerai giochi
su wii cioccolato ma è amore è ciò che i
suoi gioco no è no devo essere fuori con
le basse e mi dispiace perché volevo lì
un piatto a davoli un piatto che può
fare più prendere anche serve ok serve
fu solamente cibo sempre cibo ma non
rispecchia volano eccolo eccolo amore
sono con l'elio possono di aree a olio
amore non è che se li mangia e se
sarebbe pd come mangiare al sacco
posso farlo questa marea ciao
incredibile come fai a fare le fettine
di dio senza lelio devo farlo io non mi
farò una cosa veramente brutta tipo si
vada sarà così per parlare così però
ognuno al suo superpotere come sito come
lo hai un pari che partisse non ho mai
visto paolo ciao palla ma fatta tipo che
parola di ci fai l'attrice di tu se lo
sapevo la bbc palla tanto vediamo ancora
il cibo collegio che volava a ma vada
senti tieni si mangia in food una sega
non vuole può contro yes rifacciamo
daccapo d'ora in poi il marito ideale
arrivare alle marito ideale amore be
nice
quindi se ti svegli a pugni se ti odia
se ti amo non fa niente è proprio
realistico questo gioco un sacco uguale
è veramente così da belec no no no
sbagliate cup serve food
siamo ora prendi è così incazzato che
non avrà fatto così talmente veloce che
non l'abbiamo mai vista ma tutto un
cetriolo guarda l'ombra torna l'ombra
quasi un tic tac gigantesco mafiose
ecco perché ti odio un po di ama e che
il gran quello le mie forme insomma
guarda la differenza tra chi sta
parlando amore sono un cetriolo
lo so che volevi di più dalla vita però
questo mi hanno dato come forma a noi
era molto di più adesso bello era sicura
cambiata l'aria attorno ha potuto tanto
gramma senso firenze non a caso punto
free anzi ma voi decentrate non è
neanche se non ho appoggiato malissimo
tra l'aquila e billups il cellulare è
rimasto ai ragazzi e bergognone è
rimasta la scritta france senza tv siamo
ragazzi su check cleese stavolta che
sempre più o meno quello di prima però
un po peggio forte in salita ed argini
anche new light a candle cioè traduci
c'è troppo l'oscurità qua dentro poi
accendere piccoli andata a bra grazie
sei piaciuto corretto l'unico traduco in
questa musica bruttissimo prima era un
cetriolo adesso sono una mano si vada
visto non ci arrivo a prendere il corpo
non si abbassa la marmi il destro
adesso fare così
no no richiedono una sagoma sapri
maestri artigiani d'amore io ho eccolo
eccolo candela o col di un tour chance
on wine un laboratorio giovani quelli
meno dalle aree tematiche anche non è
una [ __ ] vorrei dire non ha gli occhi le
pupille pupilla un naso contro il mio
credo che nella bella roba molto naso in
realtà e roberto io che incredibile se
ti metti il diritto alla stessa faccia
berna ha un sedere granillo prima me
prima le signore stand i 91 dollari non
accusiamo cosa abbiamo preso hannah
montana diminuiscano sono i cremaschi
good hands free play la mia famiglia mi
aspetto questo pesa 23 mag a sono due
mega in meno di coli prima dobbiamo
andare al ribasso giochiamo a giochi
sempre meno pesanti a furia di provare
giochi sempre più leggeri allora questo
è sono 20 mega di gioco e ci giocavo io
da bambino quando esiste nel sai cosa
facevo io su penta bando si io quando
scendevo complete alle prime volte nella
mia vita faceva esattamente questa cosa
che vi sto per disegnare ragazzi hanno
provato tre giochi c'è giochi molto
divertenti
grazie cicciobello vacanza tempo il nome
grazie a te perché lorenzo grazie a te
ma se dico grazie a te vuol dire che io
sto dicendo grazie a noi noto che andare
affanculo hai capito ha ragione scuse
all'esame mentre chiediamo se facciamo
quello che sappiamo fare meglio
impersonare i personaggi dei videogiochi
quindi vi lasciamo con questa nozione
[Musica]